let me start with Kaepernick your
reaction to what you saw and how the
internet kind of grabbed ahold of it and
put it in a tourniquet what do you think
yeah I mean I think I've changed my mind
a little I reacted like a lot of people
like initially saying it even if you
thought this protest was it was
admirable or had merit it's he's the guy
to do it a quarterback making 12 million
who struggled for two years but I guess
that's really not the case because then
I thought okay what if cam newton is how
would we be happier with that i don't
think so i think we'd be pretty unhappy
with that the only problem I have I'd
say the main problem i have it is
argument that this flood this isn't
about the military and that's not what
he sees with the flag well when when we
have people in the south pulling the
Stars and Bars saying this isn't about
slavery that's not what it means to us
we dismiss that pretty quickly so why do
we give him a break on what this flag
means to him when it does have obvious
military meanings to most of us what if
Kaepernick did this as a member of the
Dallas Cowboys oh that would be that
would be unfortunate just an unfortunate
decision by him I mean San Francisco
might be one of the places where the
place yeah I'm sure there's a lot of
49er fan to haters don't get me wrong
but yeah we would not it would not play
well in Dallas so would it be obvious
when he get cut I don't think so I don't
think Jerry Jones would do that I mean
here's the thing now I mean he's barely
played and he hasn't played well and
they might have been planning to cut him
for obvious financial reasons anyway if
they didn't think he can play but a st.
cut him everybody's going to say it's
good this Jim Callis sean dallas morning
news around the horn star joining us dan
patrick show when you saw Romo first go
down your thought was
I thought that looks bad and I thought
wow I've tried to make the argument that
he's not injury prone maybe maybe that
wasn't a good argument to make you know
the fact that he was up walking around
shortly after that it still made you
think he can't get hit he this happens
when he gets in and he wears all that
that's why people think he's fat which
he's obviously not he's got so much
protected stuff under there and still it
doesn't help and so even if it's what we
think it is now I mean does anybody
think he's going to come back and then
play the next eight or nine games or
whatever's left without injury I don't I
don't think anyone thinks that any
official word from the Cowboys on romo
but none at all because Jason Garrett is
never forthcoming on injuries you won't
even rule him out for the open because
that's what Jason Garrett does Jerry
meanwhile is his own doctor he will give
us he will give him some medical
information immediately after the game
before the doctors have finished he'll
be all six to ten weeks but so but I
mean he has to wear this brace he's
supposed to wear this brace for five or
six weeks so he's not playing until
sometime in October at the very least so
how is the view on dak Prescott changed
or has it changed because he's been
almost perfect in the preseason that's
funny because it was such a disaster
here last year obviously 1 and 11 in the
game's Romo didn't start and I would say
a lot of people and I am in this group
don't think from a football standpoint
there will be a drastic change now I
mean it's three preseason games it's 50
passes or whatever he's thrown but he
certainly looks like he can do a lot of
things and we've seen Russell Wilson
we've seen rg3's rookie year he was very
good I mean quarterbacks can do it and
he is helped by the fact that you know
they should have the best running game
in the league so it's not like coming in
to play for you know the Patriots where
you got to throw it 40 times a game to
have a chance for success I view this
sort of like the Ravens when
the Ravens started Joe Flacco they had
injuries to their quarterback and Flacco
came in they had a good running game at
a good defense and then they sort of it
eased II Men to say you don't have to
make a lot of big plays mm-hmm is Jason
Garrett going to do that with dak
Prescott or is he going to say let's run
the same offense that Tony runs well I
think they were going to do that anyway
with Tony I mean that was that was to
protect Tony and to protect his defense
then a whole idea and drafting zekiel
Elliot mr. repeat 2014 and get back to
being the best running team in the
league keep the ball for 33 minutes a
game and let Tony thrown four hundred
passes about 600 so that won't change I
mean they they want to be a very
run-heavy team but they can do a few
things with Prescott obviously that they
couldn't do with Roma I mentioned that
they luck into dak Prescott they did
their best to try to screw this up the
last couple of years from Manziel to
Paxton Lynch to Connor Shaw you know
they could have bought brought in Nick
Foles you know they still don't have
that veteran backup quarterback here and
then dak Prescott gets a DUI falls in
the draft and next thing you know they
have to settle for him and he's the
starting quarterback is there a scenario
though Tim can dak Prescott actually win
this job this year you mean go out and
play and keep it yeah you mean like if
they're six and two well Jerry Jones
come out and say Romo's had a setback
we're going to keep you we're going to
give you're under wraps and rest of the
year yeah I I think that's unlikely but
obviously if Prescott plays really well
the fans here always love the backup
quarterback more than the starter and it
would create a very if he keeps playing
like this it would create a very
extensive area are you one around the
horn later today ah Danny we are off
this week for the US Open oh no this is
in your wheelhouse now Tim oh my gosh we
got Prescott we got Kaepernick we got
Dallas stuff we got the Rangers just
dominating the high maybe not the range
and maybe nothing okay probably
I not go back yeah that's not a topic
barber yeah but no no shows this week oh
man well we appreciate you giving your
hot takes that you would save for around
the horn forever the only place you're
going to get it right at the paper this
week oh this is it is it whatever I've
got I'm filling it right here mclovin
can we label this exclusive with
countless Shah on the Dan Patrick show
any particular thing you said or just
the whole thing the whole thing it's
just one big hot take or one big hot
mess one of the two yeah thank you Tim
all right Danny that's tim cowlishaw
dallas morning news and sometimes on
around the horn when the open sign on
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience